one of the greatest things that you need
to do that really helps you raise your
standards is be around people who are
more high achieving in that thing
be around people who are more high
achieving in the thing that you want to
get great at the thing that you are weak
at
so
if i was hanging around bodybuilders all
day i'd probably work out a lot more
right because everybody's doing it
because they have a higher standard
where i might let myself off the hook
for not doing a workout i'm going to see
them crushing it they're going to lift
me up they'll just have to they'll lift
me up and i'm gonna make them believe in
themselves more that's just gonna happen
i was on twitch streaming last night
league of legends and a guy said man
you're so positive twitch is such a
negative toxic place and you're here
spreading positivity like yeah and i'll
keep doing it and no matter no matter
who comes in who's negative and toxic
i am more confident in my positivity and
belief than you are in your negativity
and toxicity and so i will make you
doubt yourself because of my confidence
whoever's more confident with